[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVE BAZYL: Hi everyone.
Thanks for joining today's
Google Developers Live.
Today we have two special
guests, Brian and Cheryl from
the Drive SDK engineering team
from Boulder, Colorado.
And today we're going to talk
about the Real Time API that
we've released just a
couple of weeks ago.
And I got a bunch of questions
from the Google Drive
developers community
about the API.
And today is when those
questions will get answered.
So Brian and Cheryl, can you
just give yourself a quick
introduction?
Let people know about
what you've been
working here on at Google.
BRIAN CAIRNS: Hi, I'm Brian.
I'm an engineer on
Drive Real Time.
And I've been working on Drive
Real Time for actually almost
18 months now.
Pretty much since I joined
Google about two years ago.
CHERYL SIMON: Hi, I'm Cheryl.
I've been working on the Drive
Real Time for a shorter amount
of time, since about the
beginning of the year.
Just helping get it released
to you guys.
STEVE BAZYL: OK, cool.
And for those who aren't that
familiar with the API, can you
just give the 30 second pitch
as to what this API is, why
did we actually release
this API.
BRIAN CAIRNS: So I like to
phrase it in terms of two
things that this
API gives you.
The two big things are storage
and collaboration.
We all know when you're writing
a web application that
dealing with the network and
dealing with having to store
your state persistently, that's
a complex problem.
And we solved that for you.
And then we also give you the
ability to have real-time
collaboration that works just
like it does in all the other
Google Docs editors, Doc
Sheets and Slides.
So if those are things that
interest you, either one, then
this might be the API for you.
STEVE BAZYL: Cool.
And the API as it is now
is a JavaScript API.
So it's primarily targeted
for web applications.
We received a lot of interest
from people asking about
support for other API, other
languages, other platforms,
such as Dart, Android,
and iOS.
Are there any tips or advice
for people who want to use
Bricks I'll say on mobile for
example, or the Realtime API.
Bricks is internal name for
people who are out there.
CHERYL SIMON: Yeah, so right
now it's primary
a JavaScript API.
But we're hoping in the future
to be able to expand it to
other languages like Java, which
would allow you to do it
in Android and iOS.
That's sort of the
future plan.
BRIAN CAIRNS: Yeah so are
goals is to have native
support for Java.
I can't give any sort of
real timetable on that.
But it's certainly something
we're working on.
And then we also a plans
to do a [INAUDIBLE]
C API.
Beyond that we don't have
any specific plans.
But we certainly are happy to
look into any new language if
there's enough demand.
One thing you can do right now,
and this is something
that a number of developers
actually talked about doing,
is if you have a platform where
you can run a JavaScript
engine, it may be possible to
embed the API using the
JavaScript Edge.
On Android and iOS you
have web views.
And we know that there are a
number of developers who are
trying to sort of combine native
UI with the data stored
in this web view to get that
kind of capability.
STEVE BAZYL: That would be an
actually really interesting
thing to see if people can get
that working really well.
I suppose you could even do
similar things on the server
side with the Node
JS for example.
BRIAN CAIRNS: Yeah, Node is
definitely a good option.
Our JavaScript API
is not really--
it doesn't do really any
DOM manipulation.
So if you have a framework like
Node or something like
that, as long as it supports
external HTTP requests and
some fairly standard JavaScript
constructs, there's
a pretty good chance that
the API will work.
I mean we don't promise support
outside of browsers
but we'd certainly like to see
all kinds of interesting
places to use the API.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, I'm sure
there'll be somebody out there
who is going to try that
experiment probably not too
long from now.
BRIAN CAIRNS: I should add,
sorry, we also have a
developer who used Dart.
STEVE BAZYL: I think
this question
actually came from him.
This was Adam Singer, who's been
a pretty active member of
the community, and I know
does a lot with Dart.
He did a really cool demo of
Dart and the Realtime API.
BRIAN CAIRNS: So if you're
writing Dart or Type Script,
or another one of those
languages, even Git, that
compiles JavaScript, we'd love
to see independent libraries
if you have something great.
STEVE BAZYL: So related to this,
I think Adam had also
asked about whether or not this
API is built on the same
infrastructure as the Drive API
for example where we have
discovery documents.
I think a lot of this was
motivated by could they
generate their own libraries
for this if they wanted to
based on discovery?
CHERYL SIMON: So you can build
on top of the existing API,
but the way that the
collaboration works, the
client side logic is a little
more heavyweight than in your
typical API.
So you really need to build it
on top of the existing code
that we provide.
It would be fairly challenging
to go generate
your own from scratch.
BRIAN CAIRNS: Yeah, kind of one
of the requirements in the
API, and this is really what
precludes just making it a
rest type API, is that
operations on the data model
have to be done more or
less synchronously.
Because there's a whole process,
there's a whole
transformation process and other
machinery that has to
work so that your document
doesn't get out of sync.
And we could build a restful
API, but then your application
would have to be written kind
in a kind of synchronous,
serialized way, which of course
no one really wants.
STEVE BAZYL: Makes
a lot of sense.
So a little bit different topic,
some of the developers
have asked about testing.
How do they--
especially things like automated
test, integration
unit tests.
Are there any tips or strategies
that you would
suggest to people who are
starting to build apps but
want to practice good
coding practices?
BRIAN CAIRNS: Well I know in
the past we've had actually
internal developers here at
Google builds fake versions of
the data model that just store
their data in memory.
And one of the nice things
about the way that the
Realtime API works is because
these objects look and feel as
if they are local, it's not
unreasonable to build
something like that and
sort of swap it out.
And the dynamic nature of
JavaScript helps a lot with
something like that.
If there's a lot of demand for
that, we'd certainly would
like to see either a third
party library or if there
isn't a third party library,
certainly suggest it.
And we'll look at maybe doing
something first party.
STEVE BAZYL: That'd
be very cool.
I think you're right.
This is definitely something
that the community probably
could build pretty easily given
the API has a fairly
small footprint.
So Cheryl, a couple days ago
there was a thread in the
Google Plus community.
Somebody was asking about some
list operations and doing
things like re-ordering.
And you had given a pretty good
answer there about some
of the complexities of working
with things like Lists and
Maps in an eventually consistent
model like what the
Realtime API gives you.
You could just give you an
overview of kind of why some
things that you might take for
granted in a local model just
aren't quite as easy or might
be a little bit unexpected
behaviors in a collaborative
environment?
CHERYL SIMON: Sure.
So the way that the
collaboration--
so there are sort of two pieces
to this collaboration.
One is the fact that for
the user that their
changes appear instantly.
So they don't even necessarily
realize that there's a lot of
network things going on.
And then we also guarantee
eventual consistency.
So any changes that happen
locally will eventually make
it to the server and to all
the other collaborators.
So those two pieces together,
the way that that's
accomplished means that some
sort of your standard
techniques for dealing with
locking or synchronicity don't
necessarily work in
this environment.
So it helps to have a little
bit different mindset when
you're thinking about the data
model and how you make changes
to guarantee consistency
in your state.
So the example was if you want
to reorder a list, which ends
up being sort of an insert
and delete at
sort of the same time.
But the problem is that if two
collaborators simultaneously
try to move where something is
in the list, it's possible
that things, that you would end
up with duplications in
your list, or things wouldn't
turn out exactly how you
expect it to.
So when you're building this
kind of model, you really need
to think about--
there's a lot of trade
offs to be made.
And you need to think about your
particular use case and
how you want to trade it off.
So maybe it's OK if something
ends up in the list twice.
So one technique to sort of
guarantee that things arrive
together is to use a
compound operation.
So within the compound
operation, you do the add and
you do the remove.
So then you know that nobody
would ever receive the add and
then receive the remove
much later.
But that doesn't guarantee that
you couldn't have two
adds and removes that
would still end up
causing some problems.
So the alternative is
to sort of flip
your data model around.
And things that you want to
guarantee happen together you
have to do in a more
atomic operation.
So for example setting a value
on a map, everything in the
value, as long as it's just like
a JSON type, is going to
be set autonomically.
So if anybody else set
something, it's going to
completely override.
So you can use that in
sort of clever ways
to guarantee state.
So in this example, if rather
than having a list, you have a
map from object to its location,
you can guarantee
that every object only has
a single location.
BRIAN CAIRNS: Yet another
option, and I think Cheryl
sort of addressed
both of these.
The two that we usually look
at is either you can be
tolerant of these sort
of degenerate cases.
And a good example might be you
want to restrict the list
to only having three
items or less.
We don't give you the ability
to say, this list must only
have three items or less.
And if you try to write that
logic, what ends up happening
is you'd write something like
block the insert if there are
three items on the
list already.
Well if two people try to
insert into the list and
there's already two items,
you're going
to end up with four.
And so this sort of tolerant
model would be, just ignore
the last item in the list
if you end up with four.
The other option, and I should
say this sort of tolerant
option can also be used for
things like, I want a list,
but I want it to be sorted.
You can't enforce that a list
has to stay sorted.
But what you can do is present
a sorted view of
the list to the user.
And another option is sort of
this decrease the granularity
of mutations.
And JSON values are one
great way to do that.
Another great way to do that
would be just create a new
collaborative list and insert
the items that you want into
that, and then switch out
the list you have
in the parent element.
So that guarantees that you
get either one list or the
other, but never some
combination of the two.
STEVE BAZYL: That was actually
really helpful information for
a lot of developers who are
starting to learn this model
of building applications.
I'm going to skip over
a couple questions.
So one question was someone was
wondering about how this
relates to Wave, whether or
not there's no federation
models that we're deploying
behind the firewall?
And a related question around
whether or not this is client
to client, or client
to server.
And I was just wondering
if you could
kind of just address--
I think we've already touched
on this mostly.
But if you could just kind of
address some of the basic
architecture and also just
history around Wave and so on?
BRIAN CAIRNS: So Wave
of course--
Wave was the first operational
transformation based product
we released at Google and was
the first API certainly of an
operational transformation
based
product that we released.
So the real-time collaboration
feature in Wave do share a lot
of heritage with what we have
in the Realtime API.
It's unfair to say that
we're built on Wave.
Because Wave was very different
in many respects.
It had a lot of more email like
features and embedding
and things like that
that we don't have.
So our infrastructure looks
a lot more like what Doc,
Sheets, and Slides looks like.
When we say they we're
bringing you the same
collaborative technology as
Docs, Sheets, and Slides, we
really do mean that.
This is very much the same
sort of server and other
infrastructure that
we use internally
to build these products.
And one of the things about this
infrastructure is it's
sort of focused on client server
interactions on the web
and even when you're on non
web enabled devices.
We all know about NAT and
firewalls and all this other
[INAUDIBLE].
And so developing a peer to
peer product that works
consistently and reliably
is really a challenge.
And so as a result we--
and because you want persistent
storage--
we send all of the changes
through our servers and then
broadcast them out to the
different people who are
collaborating on the document.
We'd love to see some
sort of federation.
Right now there's not really a
standard for how that would
look or how we would do it.
And I know that with Wave there
was a lot of work on
getting federation that I would
say didn't really yield
the kind of broad acceptance
that we would have
liked to have seen.
So if there's a desire for this,
this is something we can
work on it.
But right now for better or
worse this is a product that
is offered as a service and
offered as something that
Google provides, and not
something that you would host
on your own servers.
STEVE BAZYL: Thanks.
So somebody was asking what are
some good strategies for
porting an existing app.
If you already have a JavaScript
application, what
are things that you
should focus on.
CHERYL SIMON: The exact sort
of process depends a lot on
what your applications is.
But so basically the important
piece that you need to sort of
inter operate with
the Realtime API
is your data model.
And if you already have an
existing data model that is
built up of JSON objects or
things like that, one way to
sort of make the switch
over is to make use
of the custom objects.
Which allows you to basically
take an existing JavaScript
object and tie it to the
Realtime data model by just
registering your type and
marking which fields you want
to be collaborative.
Other things we've seen are
people just making use of sort
of JSON value types and putting
those into the model.
BRIAN CAIRNS: We should be clear
to distinguish between
custom types.
In a custom type, collaboration
is on the
property level.
So if you make a custom type and
it has property a, b, and
c, modifying b and modifying
a, those get processed
separately and merged together
potentially at the same time.
With these JSON values, the
entire JSON value is one
immutable value.
So if user a changes it and then
user b changes it, you
see either user a's result or
user b's result, but never a
merge of the two.
So that's sort of up to you
to decide which is more
appropriate for your app.
STEVE BAZYL: And how important
is just having good
application architecture.
I know in our docs, we certainly
stress following any
of the model view patterns
that are out there.
How important is it that
developers stick to
established frameworks or
at least good hygiene?
CHERYL SIMON: If your model is
cleanly separated from the
view in the presentation layer,
it's going to make it a
lot easier for you
to integrate.
Because it's just such
an independent piece.
If things are mixed up together,
it can make it a
little bit more challenging.
BRIAN CAIRNS: We should add, if
you have a clean separation
of the model from your
presentation layer, it really
is a benefit if you want to do
the Drive Realtime API plus
some other form of storage.
If you want to support local
storage or you want to have
the option of storing data on
your own servers or something
like that, it's certainly
possible to use to Drive
Realtime API just as your model
layer, and then share
presentation code across.
And we have developers who
are already doing that.
I should say one other thing
that some developers have
tried with differing results.
A lot of apps have XML as their
data format and there's
multiple ways you can
try to do this.
One thing that the developers
have done with pretty good
success is sort of break up the
XML into elements and then
store those elements in
a tree like structure
in the Drive API.
And that will work
pretty well.
One thing that appears to work
well but may not work as well
as you think it does is just
sticking the XML on a
collaborative string.
You get reasonable results as
long as no one collaborates on
things that are close
together.
And once you start collaborating
on things close
together, you can end up with
things like mismatched tags
and tags that don't have closing
or angular brackets
and things like that.
So if that is your model, you
probably have to add some sort
of validation logic and do extra
work on top of that.
So if you are XML based, we
definitely recommend you split
up your XML into a tree
type approach.
STEVE BAZYL: Great.
So related to this was somebody
who was asking--
I think that somebody
was Ali--
does the Realtime API play well
with existing JavaScript
frameworks like Angular JS?
I'll actually answer this one
myself since I've been playing
a lot with Angular.
And actually it works really
well together.
I actually just answered
somebody's question on stack
overflow yesterday this with
a couple highlights.
But the one thing I actually
really like about doing it
with Angular is you don't really
have to worry about any
of the remote events.
Basically just having one object
change listener at the
root of the model and just
telling Angular to go figure
out what change, what needs to
be re-drawn just makes getting
all those real-time behaviors
really nice.
There are some issues like with
collaborative strings are
a little bit difficult
to work with.
But actually I'm probably going
to release in a reusable
snippets or things like findings
and everything to
make that really easy
for developers.
Yeah actually I found that it's
very easy to get all the
cool user features of the
real-time collaboration
building with Angular, because
of the way it does events and
the way it does dirty checking
of models and so on.
Do you guys have any particular
tools or frameworks
for building any of the samples
that you've been
working on or do you just
kind of stick--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRIAN CAIRNS: I know I've
patched some things together
with jQuery, which has
worked really nicely.
You know It's really up
to you what you like.
We're very careful.
We don't pollute your name space
with a bunch of junk.
And because we don't
have UI, there's
not a lot of direction.
We're not going to
say you should do
things x way or y way.
If you want to use a different
UI framework, or you want to
use a different JavaScript
framework, that's great.
We have worked pretty hard to
try to stay close to standard
JavaScript as you can get.
CHERYL SIMON: Yeah, I mean our
goal with the API is for it to
be as lightweight as possible
while still providing the sort
of the things that the API
is supposed to provide.
So just as much as possible make
it look like you're just
working with JavaScript data
objects and events.
So it should easily tie into
basically any framework that
you're interested in.
And I think that people playing
around with it have
found success so
far doing that.
BRIAN CAIRNS: And some examples
of where this
actually shows in the product,
for example our Maps look very
much like the ECMAscript
6 Harmony Map proposal.
We worked pretty hard on Lists
to make them work similarly to
how Arrays work.
And there's a chance depending
on how tightly you want your
framework integration to
be, that some of this
stuff will just work.
The Event system is
also like this.
It's very similar to how
DOM Events work.
STEVE BAZYL: I think we
have only a couple
more questions left.
This goes back to an earlier
question about support for
different languages in API.
Somebody was asking about
Python and CURL.
But just kind of a follow up to
that is what about things
like snapshotting the model.
So if you just want it on a
server to get a here's the
current state of what
the model is.
Is there easy ways to do that
with the Drive API?
BRIAN CAIRNS: So right now
export is client side only,
unless you were to get very,
very clever and start doing
URL hacking.
We're working on integration
with the Drive API.
So that you'll be able to
import and export JSide
versions of the data model
without having to have
JavaScript or the client
libraries or
anything like that.
I should know this is not
really the full API.
This just a grab a snapshot or
replace everything that's
there with a snapshot.
But it works well in I want to
write a mobile application and
all I really care about being
able to view and make simple
changes to the data model.
It also works pretty well for
a backup kind of scenario or
if you wanted to convert the
data model into some binary
format or something like that.
STEVE BAZYL: Actually speaking
of binary formats, there's a
question about what's some of
the strategies for serializing
to binary files.
I know in documentation and I
know a couple of the apps that
were part of the launch do this
where they sync between
files that are in Drive and the
real-time versions of them.
What are some of the strategies
for when people
should do those operations?
How do they make sure that
multiple collaborators aren't
both trying to write files
at the same time,
and things like that?
CHERYL SIMON: So there's two
different ways that you can
configure your real
time model.
So if you have a binary format
that a sort of the basis of
what's being output like say
an image or something like
that, you could write your
applications so that it's
built on top of this image.
Where you have the binary image
and then you have your
real time model attached to
the image that's separate.
And in this sort of set up, the
real time model is a more
transient sort of thing.
So when you have collaborators
working on it--
when they start working on it
you can read in information
from the binary data model, and
sort of populate your real
time model based on whatever
the current state of the
binary file is.
And then what we suggest is that
collaborators are working
on it, you don't really want
to be saving back super
continuously.
Because the real time model is
going to be saving the changes
as you go along.
But then when the users sort
of hit a snap shot point or
request a save or something
like that, then you can
serialize the model and turn
it back into binary format.
BRIAN CAIRNS: I think Cheryl
addressed this partially but.
So there's really two ways to
think about binary data and
the data model.
One way to think about it is
that the model is a full
representation of what's
in the binary file.
And this is good for things like
text files or XML formats
and things that are
fairly compact.
There are some size limitations
on how much data
you can put in the data model.
And you really don't want to
do things like take a five
megabyte JPEG image and try to
put it into the data model.
Because you're not going to
be satisfied with the
performance for that.
And if you're building an
application like usually you
would use the collaborative
data model as a series of
transformations to the
original binary file.
And what we would suggest if
you're doing something like
that is keep track of the
revision number of the binary
when you opened it.
And you can do this with
the Drive API.
And it may be even helpful to
pin that revision, again using
the Drive API.
So you can be sure that it
doesn't get garbage collected
and go way.
And by doing that you can always
load in the original
binary data and then apply the
changes in your model to that.
And then when the user goes to
save or otherwise update the
binary data, and you can choose
how to do that, you
would sort of flatten your
representation back down into
this binary format and clean out
what's in the data model.
That's one option.
Another option is if you have
a full fidelity way to
represent what's in the binary
data in your real time model,
you could just copy the binary
data effectively and do some
transformation on it, and
then write that into
the real time model.
And then you don't have to
track the binary file.
You can just keep the real time
model around basically
forever and save back to the
binary file at whatever
interval you feel is appropriate
if you're doing it
on an interval or by having
the user manually save.
One thing we would suggest is
use the capabilities that are
in the Drive API, like e-tags,
to make sure that you're not
clobbering someone
else's changes.
Remember we have the desktop and
mobile clients as well for
Drive plus the web interface.
And of course we have all
these other third party
applications.
So if you are working on
something that's shared, or
even if you're working on
something that's just a single
user's file, there's a definite
possibility that that
could get overwritten while
you're working on it.
And that's something you
want to watch out for.
And we have a document and some
descriptions of exactly
how we handle these sorts
of conflict cases in the
documentation.
But the gist of it is basically
if someone writes to
the binary file while you're
editing on it, your editing
session doesn't get
interrupted.
But future people who join the
same binary file may see
something based on the
new file contents.
And it could be a little bit
tricky to handle this.
And it's sort of an unfortunate
consequence of the
fact that we're not
collaborating directly on the
binary data.
But with some reasonable
practices, you can develop an
application that's predictable
and will give your users a
good user experience
with this.
STEVE BAZYL: So the talk about
revisions is a good segue to
the second to last question,
which is are
these versioned files?
Do we support undo and redo?
How do they reflect in the
revision history in
Drive and so on?
CHERYL SIMON: So we have the
entire history of all the
changes that were made
available to us.
It's not exposed yet.
We hopefully have some new
features coming soon that will
expose some of this
a little bit more.
STEVE BAZYL: Go ahead Brian.
BRIAN CAIRNS: I should note, we
don't affect the revision
history in Drive, the simple
answer to that.
The revision history you seen in
Drive is only related to a
binary file.
And so if you're doing a binary
application then every
time you save that would
create a new revision.
And this is by the way one
reason why you might not want
to do auto save every
minute or something.
Because you end up creating
hundreds of revisions, which
is not very useful from
a user's perspective.
But yeah, changes to
the real time model
don't show up in Drive.
I mean, they don't show up in
the revision history in Drive.
STEVE BAZYL: Last question, and
this one is just from me.
What are you most looking
forward to over the next few
months in terms of applications
from the
communities?
Or anything in particular
you'd really like to see
somebody build?
Any apps that you think are
really good candidates for
this type of collaboration
feature?
CHERYL SIMON: I don't know
if there's anything in
particular.
Mostly we're excited to see
what people come up with.
Because we've had a lot of toy
apps developed internally and
seen a lot of different things
that people play around with.
And we've already seen a few
cool examples of sort of demos
from people in the community.
But we're mostly just interested
in seeing what
people come up with.
BRIAN CAIRNS: Yeah, I agree.
I think there's a lot of
opportunity for applications
that are specific to a kind of
niche, something that maybe
you wouldn't have seen if you
had to develop the entire
infrastructure and the
synchronization framework and
all of that.
So I hope to see
a lot of those.
I would also like to see
something that is really a
fully featured powerful
application along the same
lines as Docs, Sheets, and
Slides, not something that's
necessarily in one of
those categories.
And we've seen some of that
already with apps like Gantter
and draw.io and of
course Neutron is
getting really powerful.
But I want to see something
that's really rivaling what
you can do in a traditional
application, but of course
enabled with all this real
time collaboration.
STEVE BAZYL: Well thank you
both of you for your time.
I know you're busy over there.
I really appreciate the
time to do this.
But that's the end
of the questions.
I hope everyone out there either
if you're watching live
or watching later enjoy this.
And again you can always ask
more questions in the Google
Drive Developers community.
And we'll be happy to help.
And you can also find us
on Stack Overflow.
So until next week, that's
all for today.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]